le mercure bat des records je vous le
dise en titre on n'avait pas vu cela
depuis un demi-siècle dans moins six
villes de france le thermomètre s'est
envolé hier la canicule et la la chaleur
s'installe avec des températures qui
frôlent à lyon puis de 36 degrés est
davantage à une bille 400 paires
température de l'eau 24 degrés
température extérieure 30 35
avec la chaleur de ce mois de juin
toutes les plages de france comme ici
près de montpellier connaissent déjà une
fréquentation digne des mois de juillet
août
hier des records ont été battus dans six
villes lyon albi mâcon aubenas gourdon
et ambérieu-en-bugey des températures
entre 36 et 38 degrés du jamais vu
toute la france croule sous la chaleur
comme ici avignon et chacun se
débrouille comme il peut pour se
protéger pour apprécier ce efficace
comment vous faites pour vous en
prémunir
comme à chaque période de canicule les
enfants les personnes âgées sont les
personnes qui souffrent le plus
à besançon depuis le début de la semaine
trois personnes sont décédées suite à
des problèmes de déshydratation et les
médecins renouvellent leurs conseils de
prudence
il faut se mettre à l'ombre il faut se
vêtir en conséquence donc pour permettre
évaporation il faut s'hydrater
abondamment très important il faut boire
beaucoup et il faut réfléchir et l'air
ambiant par un ventilateur
éventuellement qui permet l'évaporation
de la sueur plusieurs départements sont
déjà en alerte sécheresse comme la saône
et loire
l'arrosage des cultures et le lavage des
voitures est sévèrement limité et cette
vague de chaleur devrait se poursuivre
dans les prochains jours